today here we're happy to have dana yang
who um is joining
cornell in the department of statistics
and data science as a professor
um and she's going to talk about
something a little different
uh this week but um you know something
i'm still very interested in uh so nice
to have a
wide variety of topics so take it away
dinner
thank you adam for the nice introduction
uh yeah hopefully
um after this talk i can also get you
guys interested in this type of problems
as well because i know that many of you
uh work on a very different set of
problems
but
um well maybe let me get started by
first introducing my collaborators this
is a joint work with my amazing advisors
and the jamming shoe and also our
wonderful collaborator jinding
so
you may have encountered or even worked
on planted problems
where the problem is formulated very
simply you have a planted structure
in a random network
and the goal is to recover this planted
structure from the noisy observation
so examples of this type of planted
model include
like planted cliques in erdogani graphs
and also
you could like the planted structure
could be a block structure where you
could model the noise using the
stochastic block model and then the
recovery of the block structure is
exactly the community detection problem
now aside from the very many
like unlimited potential for real
applications in both
social networks
and in other sciences
i think a big reason why this type of
problem attracts a lot of researchers
including a lot of people in the ccsi
program
is because you can ask very interesting
fundamental questions
that are of theoretical interest
and those questions they are usually
formulated as when and how can you
recover this plantar structure from the
noisy observation
so usually when you ask the when problem
you pose the problem as a statistical
question
saying that what is the best that you
can do regardless of any computational
constraints
and the how question is uh more often
algorithmic and you can ask questions in
a positive direction saying what's a
good algorithmic design for recovery and
you can ask also the neck here question
which is
what are there any algorithmic hardness
for this type of problems
so the problem that i'm going to discuss
today
is
well it's um
a very small
subset of this large sea of problems and
it's probably one of the simpler planted
models um that you have encountered
so this is when the planted structure is
just assumed to be a perfect matching in
a bipartite graph
so a bipartite graph is basically
a graph that contains say n vertices on
one side and n vertices on the other
side
and a perfect matching in a bipartite
graph is simply
a set of n edges where for each node on
the left
it is matched to its
one and unique true match on the right
and then we
assume the observation is
somewhat a noisy variant of this graph
and of course of course the true
observed graph does not really contain
the colors and therefore the goal is to
recover all the red edges by you
recovering the chew planted matching
so why do we care about this problem
well uh the motor uh the the um
uh the dominant uh motivating
application is the so-called particle
checking application
where
you have a bunch of particles that are
placed together in the same environment
and
in order to observe
their movement or their behavior you
take snapshots of their locations at
different time points
now with this these snapshots you want
to tell
which particle moved to which place in
the next time frame
and that corresponds to the recovery of
the shoe matching among these pairs of
particles
so these particles for example they
could be all kinds of organisms such as
a school of swimming bacteria
it could also be a flock of birds that
are taking off
but the difficulty is to recover like
which bird fly to which place
the next second
and being able to recover this chill
matching is important because it allows
you to recover the whole trajectory of
all these moving particles which is
crucial for the behavioral analysis
so with that let me just uh
formally state what our planted matching
model is
so you have a planted matching denoted
as m star that's drawn uniformly from
the set of all perfect matchings
so
they're denoted as the red stick edges
in the graph
and aside from those red edges we also
assume that there are a few unplanted
edges
so for each
edge that is not a red that is not a red
edge it's going to appear in the final
observed graph independently with
probability d over m where this
parameter d here is basically encoding
the sparsity level of this graph
and the uh i'm going to always be
drawing the planted edges as red and the
unplanted edges as blue
now we assume that the observed graph is
a weighted graph
where the weights
are distributed independently according
to either distribution p or distribution
q
depending on whether an edge is a
planted or unplanted edge
is the model clear so far
thank you
so uh here's our result and it can
really be summarized in one sentence
so we um
we
we characterize the sharp threshold for
almost perfect recovery of the planted
matching
okay so what do i mean by that
when i say sharp threshold i mean two
directions
first the positive direction is saying
on one side of the threshold there is
some estimator
that achieves the so-called almost
perfect recovery
meaning that so the symmetric difference
between this estimator and the choose
is of order little o n on average
so meaning that on average you can
recover
all but a vanishing proportion of all
the planted edges in the two matching
and there's also the negative direction
meaning on the other side of this sharp
threshold we show that there is no
estimator that can achieve almost
perfect recovery meaning that for any
estimator it is going to bound to suffer
at least a constant proportion of
mismatched edges
okay
and
the sharp threshold that
we show depends on two key quantities in
the model
first is the sparsity parameter d and
the other
is the body triad coefficient or some of
you may also know it has the hellinger
affinity between the two distributions p
and q
so it's basically defined as the
integral of the square root of the
product the density of the these two
distributions so uh for example um when
p and q they're the same distributions
this challenge infinity is equal to one
meaning they're both i'm sorry there's a
question yeah
uh
is it clear that the matching is unique
um
so uh in the model we assume that there
is a unique planted matching but it's
not clear that in the observed graph
there's going to be a unique perfect
matching there could be some fake ones
that show up randomly but uh like
it's just like
like i guess in
in the first case it must be sort of
there's
not necessarily because if you look at
the definition of the loss function here
um it's characterized by basically the
number of mistakes that it makes but
it's divided by n right
so it could still make a little o n
number of mistakes
yeah
but what this is saying is for almost
all the vertices on the left you're
going to successfully find this match on
the right
yeah here's my second question it's um
where does the like in your applications
where does the like the peq build
like in the like applications
um yeah so that part is
for example the reason that you're
imagining p and q as different
distributions is because for the edges
for the edges that correspond to maybe
the two matches
um if say you model the edge weights as
the amount of distance that a particle
has traveled
then it's going to be tend to be lower
than between pairs vertices that are not
perfect matches
that's the underlying motivation
sorry so just make sure you understand
so you're saying the weights are like
the distance between them
they could be
modeled by yeah for example the distance
is some kind of similarity measure
okay
it's more like a random like geometric
graph like that right here
you're taking
yes that's true
so uh in the early training graph so
this is more like a generalization of
the model
um if you think of
the sparsity level b as say it can be
taken as large as n in which case you're
just observing a complete graph where
you observe the pairs of distances
between any two pairs of nodes so our
result incorporates the particle
tracking example as a special case
because you could take i guess you could
take q to be like you know
uh oh you're right never mind yeah
yeah so i should i should really point
out that i fully admit this is a very
abstract like idealistic way to capture
the particle tracking example uh for
example if
in real life obviously the movement of
these particles
they're not going to be all
independently distributed their edge
weights they're going to be correlated
with each other which is really not
captured by this model so it's really a
approximation
thank you for all the great questions
and really please feel free to stop me
anytime in the middle of the dark
sure
now
as
i just briefly mentioned
um the result does work for both the
sparse case where d is bounded and the
dense carries where d can go to infinity
and in particular in the dense case i
should point out that we do need uh
appropriate scaling assumptions on the
distributions and
those assumptions
yeah those are those assumptions are
basically for ensuring uh when you focus
on each node and look at all its
incident blue edges because in the dance
regime there could be many of them
but if you look at the one that is the
most likely to be the right match
then its uh
likelihood per se is basically on par
with the the true red edge that is
incident too so we do need some kind of
scaling assumption in order to
make this a sharp threshold without hold
[Music]
not necessarily
so like a high weight matching in some
cases uh they could correspond to like
the maximum likelihood estimator for
this problem
um but uh that estimator is uh it's uh
just not obvious at all that that
estimator is going to be optimal for the
task of almost perfect recovery
and so the goal is always there is an uh
planted matching to start with
this is the matching that is in the
graph but you don't observe it and the
goal is now based on the random ways
that is observed you want to recover
what it is but the truth is always
unique
so some uh important examples of that
that our result applies to
um one example is the so-called
exponential model uh this is actually a
model that has a sort of rich history
which
i will get you later in the talk um it
has been studied quite extensively in
the literature before and i'm going to
discuss its significance later but it's
basically this
special case where d is equal to n where
you basically observe a complete graph
and p and q are both exponential
distributions but with different rates
and it has been conjectured in the
literature that the sharp threshold for
almost perfect recovery happens that
lambda equals four so this is indeed
rigorously shown in our paper as a
special case of our result
another important
way
yeah another important example is the
so-called unweighted model so this is a
model that's in the sparse regime where
the
sparsity parameter d
is a constant and the p and q are the
same distributions
so note that when p and q are the same
basically the edge weights that you
observe they don't offer any additional
information that helps you peel apart
the red edges from the blue edges so
it's as if you're just observing an
unweighted graph
so in this case
the body charge coefficient
is equal to one exactly
so the sharp's threshold
collapses to the very clean threshold of
d equals one
so that is saying
for each vertex if the average number of
its fake matches that you observe
is smaller than 1 then it is possible
to almost perfectly tell apart all the
red and blue edges
but
if the average degree d is
like even
1.001 then that task is no longer
possible
so this is really the type of result
that just surprised me when i first
realized it because it's just so simple
and intuitive and it just
made me question like you know
has this really not been shown by
someone 10 years ago being like a
two-page paper
so
um but the point that i'm trying to make
here today is for this type of problems
even for the very simply stated problems
there could be a surprising amount of
subtlety behind them
and
for this problem in particular we
actually ran into some very unique
challenges
that caused the more
standard prominent
analysis methods to fail
which is why today i would like to take
some of the limited time to highlight
some of the proof techniques that
allowed us to establish this sharp
threshold
because
in fact for this problem at least for me
i feel like the analysis is even more
interesting than the results themselves
so from now on for simplicity i'm just
going to focus on the unweighted model
so let's just forget about the weights
and assume that we only observe an
unweighted graph and we want to
establish these two directions of the
sharp threshold least two directions of
the sharp threshold right so first the
positive direction this one is
relatively easy so let's just do it as a
warm-up exercise we want to establish
that till when d is smaller than one
there is an estimator that succeeds in
particular i'm going to look at the
maximum likelihood estimator
and the nice thing about the unweighted
model is
because the weights
are
all gone um
all the perfect matchings that show up
in the graph they're going to have the
same likelihood
and as a result the maximum likelihood
estimator is simply an arbitrary member
of
the set of perfect matchings in the
graph
now from here
the rest of the proof basically follows
from a very standard first moment
analysis or maybe you also know it as
just the union bound
and then you can show that the
average error of the
maximum likelihood estimator does go to
zero in probability when d is smaller
than one okay
the far more interesting direction is uh
establishing the negative direction
and for this part i do want to take some
time
and i want to try to convey the key
ideas in the proof maybe with the help
of a lot of pictures
so
our proof goal is going to rely on a few
very crucial observations
first of all i claim that the
estimator that samples from the
posterior distribution is optimal by a
factor of 2.
what i mean is that if m kyoda is the
estimator that's sampling from the
posterior then we can show basically via
a triangle inequality and the base rule
that for any other estimator m hat
its
loss cannot beat the loss of this
posterior sampling estimator by a factor
of two
so what this means is for the analysis
of
the optimal estimator it is enough just
to look at the posterior sampling
estimator because if any estimator
succeeds then so must and total
the next observation is that uh
um we actually have some understanding
about the posterior landscape of this
problem because for the light uh for the
unweighted model as we were saying the
likelihood is the same for all perfect
matchings showing up and because the
prior is uniform the posterior
distribution is simply going to be a
uniform distribution over the set of all
perfect matchings
or you can
imagine the set of all perfect matchings
in the graph
um
as uh showing the picture here you can
think of m star the truth as the center
of all these matchings
you can divide the space of possible
matchings into a good set and a bad set
where in the bad set
um
the matchings are going to make at least
a small constant delta times n number of
edge mistakes
now our key proof uh idea
is basically showing that there is
exponentially many so there are
overwhelmingly large number of bad
solutions that show up with high
probability
now
because the posterior distribution is
simply a uniform distribution
over
the space
so when someone samples from the
posterior
with high likelihood they're going to
end up in the bad region and therefore
suffer a constant proportion of
mismatched edges
so that's the idea
now how do we prove that that there are
these exponentially many bad solutions
well
we do that by characterizing what the
symmetric difference from any genetic
matching to the truth looks like
and i claim that this metric difference
is always going to consist of a disjoint
union of alternating cycles
and this
simply follows from the fact that for
each vertex that shows up in the
symmetric difference
it's going to be incident
to its uh um a unique
uh to match edge
and
the fake hedge
now
this uh what these all three
observations combined together allows us
to conclude is now we're able to reduce
the problem to simply showing the
existence of exponentially many
long alternating cycles
in the graph
now sorry i forgot to mention that when
i say a cycle is alternating it's
basically a cycle that goes planted
unplanted planted unplanted until it
completes the cycle
because
every
alternating cycle would correspond to
a solution
would correspond to at least a matching
that is in g
and if the alternating cycle is long
then it's going to correspond to at
least a bad matching engine which is why
it suffices now to show the existence of
exponentially many distinct alternating
cycles
and uh
if you are familiar with the standard
techniques for this type of problem the
first idea that might come to mind is
the first and second moment method
which is basically you look at the set
of all
alternating long cycles
and then you look at their first and
second movement
so for this problem the first moment is
indeed exponentially large
but
um
there's a trouble for the analysis for
the second moment so usually if you're
able to show that the second moment is
at most like on par with the the first
moment squared
then via the koshi shia's inequality you
can show that with at least some
constant probability
um the
uh the number of long alternating cycles
is going to be also exponentially large
however the issue for this problem is
the second moment it actually probably
blows up
and this is due to the excessive
correlation among these long cycles
because note that s is a set of these
very long cycles so many of them are
going to share a lot of edges
and for those pairs sharing edges they
contribute to correlation that ends up
to blow up so the difficulty here is
really how do we control these type of
correlations
as a solution
we
um use the idea of sprinkling which
actually was used
um also for other problems for example
for showing the emergence of giant
components or the shiny grass and it's
also used in a previous paper by
jinding and goswami but that's in a
different context the idea of sprinkling
is basically you first
find a bunch of short pots
and then you join these short pops
better into long cycles
so it's a simple idea because
the parts that you're finding are short
so there's relatively smaller
correlation between them so that's the
idea
now
let me formally introduce what the
two-stage cycle finding scheme is doing
at the start you reserve a set of
vertices that you're going to use for
sprinkling
now in stage 1 you construct a bunch of
parts
that are disjoint and then they're short
and you're going to only use the
unreserved vertices
and in the second step which is the
sprinkling step
you connect all these parts together
into
long cycles
so here is a picture
explaining what it's doing
you have a set of reserved vertices v
unreserved v complement
you find
short
disjoint path
in this set
and then
connect them
through
edges from v to v complement
and also
amongst v itself
in order to form
the final desired circles
of cycles so that is the proof idea
now the hope is that
among v and between v2 or v complement
these guys are going to be fell fairly
well connected
so that
it allows you to
um um find exponentially many
possibilities to join these short paths
together
now that is the hope
unfortunately that turned out to be
wishful thinking
in fact uh when we're analyzing this
model they turned out these um between v
and the v complement and the monster v
itself it's not so well connected
so very unfortunately we have to
resort to
a slight variation
of this model
of this method
which is instead of starting with
finding disjoint parts
we're actually going to start by finding
disjoint bushes
and the reason why there's some
advantage to using these bushes
is that these bushes they are
freely growing they contain a lot of
vertices
and all of their
vertices are actually reaching out to
connect to the set of reserved vertices
therefore to sort of boost up the level
of connectivity
of
in the sprinkling stage
so this is a
very bad drawing for
illustrating the idea
but uh
um here
yes i'm going to get to that
yes there are some techniques there
there are some small subtleties
regarding the construction of the bushes
because you also want to make sure that
the parts that you find in the bushes
they're alternating color so that turned
out to be a key difficulty okay
now
the idea is
in each bush
you're going to find a set of left
vertices say l1 here and a set of right
vertices r1
such that between l1
qr1
they are very well connected so there's
going to be
a alternating path
that starts and ends in a red edge
from any vertex to l1 to any vertex in
r1
so that's basically what a bush is going
to look like
and
once we have this the sprinkling stage
is made relatively easier
in the sprinkling stage
first
you look at the set of reserved vertices
and find the ones that are connected to
these l1r1 l2r2 sets via some blue edge
now
these vertices these reserved vertices
that you'll find they're going to be
attached to their unique match
via red edges
now the final step is
if you can find
some blue edge that connects u1 to v2
prime
or and u2 to v1 prime then i claim you
have found your alternating cycle
and the reason is because
the path construction stage already
gives you alternating paths p1 p2 that's
start and ending red edges
so your path goes like this
essay starts with
a vertex in l1 goes through the
alternating path
ending a red edge then goes blue red
and then blue red blue
red blue
and you can go back and complete the
alternating cycle
so
a key idea
um well a key observation
from this picture is that
the only two edges that we need to
ensure the existence of to complete the
cycle
are these two crossing
blue edges
because all the edges all the other
edges they
exist by construction
so in a way
you can take a step back and really look
at this graph
as just four giant nodes
in what we call
a super graph
and you can collapse down this graph
into a super graph with a planted
matching and you want to show the
existence
of blue edges that connect the nodes in
the super graph
now
a few details that i have not mentioned
uh i have not mentioned
well whether or not the super graph is
actually well connected enough for the
sprinkling stage to work
um also how exactly are we constructing
the bushes
and the most importantly i have not
mentioned to you where we are using the
condition that d is larger than one
so that can all be answered
in the path construction scheme
so to slale's question before this says
how we grow the bushes
we're going to grow it by centering at
an arbitrary red edge
now to the left and to the right we're
going to grow
their respective trees
so it's going to be basically like a
breath first search
and
during the search we make sure that we
all we always explore
in alternating colors
and you can see that
this breadth first search can be
basically viewed as a branching process
whose
average offstring whose offspring
distribution depends only on the number
of blue neighbors each node has
and the average degree of the blue edges
is exactly characterized by d
which is why when d is larger than one
with at least some constant probability
this branching process is going to
survive giving you as many offspring as
you want
and the reason that we want a lot of
offspring for these bushes is we want
them to reach out and connect to the
angry to the reserve vertices
which uh because that's going to lead to
large enough u-sets and v-sets
which in turn is going to ensure the
very super criticality or ensure that
the super graph is very well connected
and that's how our argument basically
comes for full circle
okay i'm going to stop here for just a
second are there any questions
so
i guess that here you've illustrated
this more or less for the for the
uniform weight space uh but i guess
is it easy to see how it can change if
you have different weights uh yes
actually i i do have some backup slides
for that one
that's a great question
so you see that for the
[Music]
for the planet model what happens is um
you still have the observations one
three the only observation that no
longer holds is the posterior
distribution is no longer uniform
therefore not only do you need to find
exponentially many long cycles you want
to find enough long cycles that are what
we call augmenting meaning that their
likelihood is such that they contribute
to a post uh to imagine that at least
has the same likelihood as the truth
so that's just boils down to this linear
restriction on the log electrical ratios
along
the red and blue edge across the red and
blue edges in the cycle which is why
when you're constructing the parts
so now i'm just looking at a single side
of this bush
and instead of just doing a vanilla
breath research we need to implement
what's called the exploration plus
selection
um algorithm which is when you
when you're exploring when you're
exploring
periodically you're going to stop
and do a selection
step where you only select the paths
that are augmenting and that is why
um if you do this periodically your and
you're going to end up with
all augmenting parts which will
contribute to augmenting cycles
so that is
some extra extra detail that we need to
do
yes basically i mean all the selected
paths
so i mean for example
uh from ik
you go down and look at this path
if this path is augmenting then you keep
it
yeah but for all the other parts you
discarded meaning you no longer keep
growing from the leaf nodes
so the goal is afterwards when you look
at
uh all the selective vertices
they're
to the root node
is always going to be an augmenting path
because it consists only of augmenting
segments
sir do you remove the ones
yeah uh well you can think of removing
them or just in the next stage of the
breath first search you no longer grow
and the edges from them
you care about like the thing that oh
yes or like
sorry
oh i should comment that uh um we need
to be quite careful about how often we
do this selection
because for example if we only do it
once at the end of the exploration stage
then it's going to throw away way too
many parts and that's going to be too
wasteful
now
i think i maybe have
minus one minute so i'm going to very
quickly go to
the exponential model which i promised
to talk about in the start of the talk
i should mention that
there is an unplanned version of this
problem where you only have blue edges
and no red edges and this is a very well
studied problem and it's first shown by
elders rigorously in 2001 that if you
look at the minimum weight matching or
you can think of it as the optimal
matching in the unplanted model then
it's going to have average weight that
converges to
a beautiful constant of pi squared over
6.
now the planted version is a model that
has only been studied more recently
in particular like in a
2019 paper by my advisor jamin shu and
his co-author maharami and more they
show they analyze the minimum weight
matching also and show that it achieves
almost perfect recovery if and only if
lambda is above the threshold four which
is why the conjecture that lambda equals
4 is indeed the
statistical limit for this problem and
this is indeed verified by our paper
and not only are we able to establish
the sharp threshold we can characterize
what the phase transition looks like
meaning that
if you draw the phase diagram
as the function of lambda
so we know that when lambda
is above four
the error is zero
we're able to
characterize
the error around the sharps threshold
and we show that when lambda is say a
small distance epsilon away from the
sharp threshold
then this error behaves like e to the
minus some constant over square epsilon
meaning that it's going to be infinitely
smooth at the phase transition
or you can think of it as revealing an
infinite order phase transition which
has been conjectured in a previous paper
by smurgios curl and
the brava
okay now at the risk of confusing the
hell out of you
for
this exponential model we actually have
to go back and now use paths instead of
bushes in order to establish this um
um
lower bound in the phase transition and
the reason is when we're trying to
establish
tight lower bounds on the error we want
to try to find the very long cycles
and
which is why when you look at these
short thick bushes
it's them being way too wasteful instead
of instead you want to look at long thin
paths and for the exponential model we
had to do a lot of additional work to
make the sprinkling step go through yes
when you started the theorem you stated
it for generic p and q yes so i guess is
is there some kind of uh
characterization of the types of
distributions for which you need to use
push resources um no actually so for the
sharps ratio lambda equals four that uh
is a special case uh that
uh that is just uh
this is only for the infinite order
phase transition yeah you obtain this uh
sharp lower bound on the error yeah
that's the place we need it
and with that let me just very quickly
conclude model we established the sharp
threshold and the infinite order phase
transition under the exponential model
and the key takeaway is that the
springtime idea is really powerful
so some open problems are
can we characterize some phase
transitions for general distributions so
we actually have result in the paper for
the unweighted model saying that the
under the unwitting model the phase
transition is actually finite order so
it's not infinitely smooth so we know
the phase transition is going to be
distribution
dependent
also we're only able to characterize
what the arrow looks like near the shark
threshold
can we characterize this error across
the entire parameter range
third open problem is
the planted matching is basically a
planted one factor graph what if there
is a planted k factor graph
so for this problem it has been
conjectured
that the sharp threshold happens at
square root k times the times the bottom
chart coefficient equals one
so it will be really great to show this
rigorously
that's
everything thank you very much for
listening
any questions
okay let's thank dana again
[Applause]